entre ces femmes
la tension est palpable elles ont perdu
tous leurs biens elles ont été séparés
de leur famille durant la guerre de
corée
bienvenue sur le plateau de padoue ya
pas de ja c'est l'un des tout nouveaux
délais roman qu'on appelle leaké drama
kapoor corps et âme anglais les studios
du télédiffuseur public sud-coréen kébé
s produisent jusqu'à 20 séries chaque
année surtout des drames historiques
le directeur artistique raconte que l'un
des premiers succès winter sonata a
présenté l'accord et sous toute une
gamme d'émotions que le programme et
cela a résonné chez un large public
partout en asie du sud est
ça a été le début de la vague culturelle
coréenne dit il une vague surnommé aliou
ça inclut la mode qui fashion ou encore
la k-pop la musique populaire
d'ailleurs beaucoup de chanteurs sont
aussi acteurs les quais drama ont une
énorme base admirateurs prêt à se rendre
sur les lieux de tournage comme ici à
québec
le héros de cette série se retrouve dans
le quartier petit champlain
après avoir franchi la porte de son
bureau les téléromans sud coréens sont
généralement de courte durée quelques
dizaines d'épisodes tout au plus
diffusés en rafale ils ont une facture
visuelle particulière très léché et ils
sont largement partagées par
téléchargement ce qui contribue à leur
popularité
tout comme les thèmes abordés c'est à
dire la lutte du bien contre le mal
la fierté l'amour éternel présentées
comme autant de traits de caractère
comme partie intégrante de l'identité
sud coréenne par les producteurs
il est incarné par cet acteur très
populaire proclamé comme l'un des plus
beaux hommes de corée du sud c'est le
brad pitt locale les coréens aime se
démarquer selon sept professeurs ils
apprécient que l'on parle d'eux
autrement qu'en tant que peuple coincé
entre des grandes puissances est dit
elle
tu peux nous présenter à de tels gestes
bénigne sauf à des fins c'est-à-dire la
chine ou encore le japon ancien pays
colonisateur le gouvernement ne s'y est
pas trompé l'investît massivement depuis
des années dans la culture populaire qui
lui sert aussi d'outil de diplomatie
douce ici un libéro radio canada